let's look at uh another example and
we're going to since we've seen these
steps before they're going to be a
little easier this time so we're going
to look at the mnus data digit data set
so these are the the handwritten digits
on postal codes I think they're derived
from right that we're trying to classify
into the 10 digits class okay so as in
the hinders data set we need to we need
to give the data to torch so actually
the mnus data is already sort of
prepackaged for for torch or almost
prepackaged so we can find it with one
of the um the those libraries this torch
Vision data set has the amus data
already for us we're going to do a
slight bit of pre-processing
um actually no oh I'm sorry that's
pre-processing for the sear so we again
make a data module that tells um torch
how to load in the data uh so what this
is what will happen in um this sort of
specifies what an Epoch looks like there
are 256 per batch so an Epoch goes
through you know each of the data points
up at with a chunk of 256 until every
data point has been visited once and
then the epoch is
finished
okay
um let's specify our model now so we're
going to do now just a slightly more
complicated model but um it will be uh
it'll be a two- layer model and oh I
think I I I missed one important line in
the hitters example that I'm going to
emphasize now all of these so again
we're going to make a subclass of the
nn. module here we're going to make it
for the mnus data you can name this
whatever you like but probably useful to
name it something related to what you're
doing um and there's this line here this
super line uh that we also had for the
hitter's data so what this does is well
we inherit from the module class and we
only Define here two methods right the
this init method and the forward method
but this nn. module has many other
methods and that's of course because
this you know torch has to use this to
fit the model so it has to know how to
do many other things and um so this this
what we're doing here is actually
calling the init method of module on
this newly created mnist example so this
is actually necessary for every time
time you make a subass of and. module so
the syntax is the same throughout all
our examples we give it's the super
function which is a built-in function
the class name self and self is a
keyword here it's the the first argument
to every method and we call the init
method of well actually nn. module on
self so I just you'll have to do that
for all your examples otherwise you'll
have a problem okay so let's get to the
heart of specifying our our layers um
we're going to do two layers um so the
layers are going to be specified much
like our single layer um so this chunk
here is very similar to what we saw for
the The Hitter data set uh we're just
going to now compose two layers so we'll
store this as layer one a similar output
as layer two and then we'll compose them
with the sequential call again so
features first go into layer one come
out from layer two and then they get
mapped um to 10
and that's because we have 10 digits
here so just to get the idea the images
are 28x 28 grayscale images M so in the
layer one we see the 28x 28 um that's
the dimension of the input and and the
hidden layers got 256 units right we're
using a drop out of point4 then the
second layer of course must take 256 as
a input that dimension of the input
layer cuz that's the previous hidden
layer yeah and then it's got 128 eight
hidden
units and then and specify the Dropout
and then the final layer the output
layer goes from the
128 hidden units to the 10 dimensional
output layer because they 10 digits
right and we use a soft Max yeah they'll
be we know we don't have the soft Max
here the L function is actually going to
have the soft Max applied to it but
that's similar to the regression example
where this just describes you know how
features get transformed into outputs
and then the loss relates that to the
outcome so Jonathan we can see how easy
it would be if you wanted to just add a
few more hidden layers right we just
basically replicate this kind of code
and put in the numbers we want and it's
really straightforward you could even if
you wanted to have 10 you didn't if you
want a 10 layers you could even do in a
for Loop you don't even have to repeat
the same code and we'll do something
like that for the CNN we'll have I think
five layers or so and rather than write
writing five chunks like this we'll
we'll use Python to to make it easy so
it takes a little bit of getting used to
the this layout but once you you've got
it you can basically set up any neural
network mhm yeah and again this forward
map that's the key uh this tells how
features get translated into this case
10 the 10 scores and that'll get tied to
to
soft okay so then a lot of the rest is
going to be almost identical to before
um that part about setting up the
trainer running the and training it and
Etc but let's uh let's let's uh go
quickly rather a little quickly to that
so we'll again we'll specify the this is
instantiates the n model we can look at
the summary again
so uh the summary is a bit longer now
because we have two layers but uh it can
be read pretty similar to the hitter's
data and we're not going to spend too
much time on
that okay so here again we make this um
module that this argument here
classification says take those 10
outputs and throw them into a soft Max
to to compare it to the the response in
whatever data this thing gets fit and
again this argument here tells tells
torch what data will be fat fit into the
classification
problem after that well this is going to
look similar they'll be a lot of blue
things and we could watch them if we
were running this
live let's make a similar plot to what
we had done before for uh mean squar
mean absolute error in the hitters data
let's let's plot this metric for
accuracy for the um the mnus data and
again we can see how uh how things
progress for um training and valid and
interestingly the validation starts off
a little higher than the training data
but um in the end they're they're
they're relatively comparable but that's
just luck of the draw yeah yeah it's
about 95% uh accuracy yes yeah here's a
we can evaluate the test accuracy about
just over 95%
okay um so the last thing that we will
not go over uh for the imis data is how
to fit just a very simple uh logist U
multinomial regression model rather than
a hidden um a neural network model oh
right using basically the same code
right yes yeah so there's just no Rue no
Dropout just a just a nod layer yeah
that's right and that that's just um the
only thing that is different between
this one and the previous one is that
there was a nonlinear function to get
the 10 scores here it's just a linear
function yeah and last let's wrap up
with just looking at its
accuracy it gets about 90% on accuracy
on the test data that's still pretty
good actually still pretty good
okay